[Music]
don't touch that dial as why it unwraps
one of the hottest Innovations to hit
America's favorite pastime
television just when you thought binge
watching the latest seasons of Silicon
Valley and Game of Thrones couldn't get
any better LG has unveiled its curved
OLED TV to understand this Leap Forward
let's take a look back at the previous
advance in TV technology LC
or liquid crystal display which utilizes
light emitting diodes and millions of
pixels to create a high defin image
however the richness of LCD color
displays and the thinness of LCD screens
are limited by those extra layers of
crystals LED backlighting and additional
substrates by contrast organic LEDs AKA
oleds generate their own Illumination in
response to electric current
that means fewer layers for a screen
depth as narrow as17 in roughly the
width of a number two pencil and
speaking of things you can sharpen the
ability of OLED pixels to switch off as
necessary allows them to create deeper
more detailed and yes sharper black
levels in LCD TVs the backlight is
always on and this constant brightness
creates milky blacks which diminish
picture quality the new Leed technology
also adds a white sub pixel to the red
green and blue of traditional color
displays further boosting oled's visual
range and contrast for Bolder more
vibrant
images and that outstanding picture
quality extends to the screen itself
bringing us to the sexiest part of this
OLED TV
curviness by engaging the peripheral as
well as the central range of vision the
curved screen provides an immersive
viewing experience
as for what's next in TV Innovation well
the fact that oleds can be sprayed onto
thin plastic substrates means that
someday in the future you may actually
be able to roll up your screen when
you're done with it or as they say in TV
that's a
wrap feeling wired yet
subscribe